so max freed is the man on the mound for
atlanta as we open up this series with
the toronto blue jays all max has done
is be brilliant especially early in the
games
two quick outs no score on the top of
the first inning here's t oscar
hernandez
wrapped on the ground sharply diving
stop made it third by riley from his
knees
off ballots throw onto first wide of the
bag
in time for hernandez to cross safely
and a two out in field single for
hernandez
the cough over to first base close play
got him
mention that good pick off move out of
max freed stepped towards first base
and had tasker hernandez leaning towards
second and they got him over at first
base so he faces the minimum at the top
of the first inning
matchup making a second start of the
season great numbers against tampa bay
in game two of the season it's been a
long layoff for matt
he has been terrific in his young career
with the blue jays this will be his
seventh career start
here's marcelo zuna two outs at a runner
and third no score for now
swinging to this at the slider ozuna
goes down on strikes and matt shoemaker
dodges the bullet of a lead off walk
stranding the atlanta runner at third
base matt adams leads off
matt shoemaker worked around to lead off
walk to keep the braves off the board in
the first
swing and a fly ball wallop to center
grichik on his horse to the warning
track to the wall
she is gone a splashdown homer for matt
adams and the braves have struck first
homer number two rbi number seven
[Music]
that ball was pulverized by adams
two down for flowers one-nothing braves
are in the bottom of the second flowers
lifts one toward left center field that
one's well hit
bridging back to the wall and this one
and it's gone
tyler flowers has his first home run
two solo shots for the braves in the
second
and all of a sudden it's bombs away in
atlanta ga
two-nothing adams took him deep in the
second inning to open the scoring
three-two pitch it on a line a dive by
biggio
pick it up in the outfield throw to
first and vlad has to dive to make the
play
tremendous play on both sides by kevin
biggio
and vladimir guerrero jr biggio out in
shallow right field in the shift still
had to dive
even with all that extra room matt came
up a little gimpy
as he made his way to first in the old
grab at the back of the leg
off double followed by a walk now two
out blue jays are still looking for that
big hit here in this game
pitch to alfred breaking ball rolled off
the glove of the third baseman shooting
into left field
that'll get toronto on the board on a
ball that was absolutely rifled
off the leather of riley down at third
base it shot straight into the air and
checked up in shallow left field rbi
base hit for anthony alford who drives
in his first run of the year
and has toronto on the board here in the
fifth here's freeman
with a runner at third one out and
that's on the ground
acuna is coming hello and he beat the
ramp with the infield in
great speed by acumia who
[Applause]
runners on it first and second here in
the fifth austin riley walked his last
time up he's also struck out
see if he can get a hold of one braves
up three to one
riley hits it in the air toward alfred
in left to the warning track to the wall
won't get there it's a home run for
riley
a three-run bomb into the toronto
bullpen
and alfred took some punishment he tried
to climb the wall and couldn't get there
in time
it's six to one speed and power the
story for atlanta
two out from the batter's guriel who has
doubled and grounded out
and fires got him swinging strikeout
for freed and that's his third of the
night
two down for oscar hernandez
righty-righty matchup
got him looking strike three my goodness
he carved him up there in the eighth
inning
josh tomlin with a one two three frame
braves threatening to add
on here with dansby swanson dansby has a
sixth inning hit in four trips
and a shot hit toward third that's under
the glove of panic and into left field
that's going to score in ciarante here
comes acuna
flying around third look at him come to
the plate standing up
acuna scores from first on a double by
dansby and the braves are pouring it on
man oh man when acuna gets going he
finds a gear that
mere mortals don't have he went around
second base and he didn't even look at
wash he knew he was going the whole time
8-1 atlanta in game one against
toronto that's another shot smoked off
panic's glove
and streaking around third is dansby
he's going to score it's going to be
nine to one nothing for panic he's
getting some bullets in adam
yeah cargo one for two
this one's launched to right field
that's over the head of hernandez that's
off the brick wall
that ricochets back toward the infield
they're going to send duval
home throw comes into second toronto
doesn't recognize duvall never stop
running
he scores from first on a double and the
braves just
continue to assault warner font he's two
outs
in a 10-1 game he's 50-50 balls and
strikes so far
as this one's hitting the air to left
duval is under it and the braves have
won it
10-1 the final score three homers for
the atlanta ball club